al final de la calle a pocos metros de
estas casas el fuego hace estragos los
vecinos de larage en el norte de
Marruecos están angustiados los bomberos
luchan para evitar que las llamas se
extiendan por la provincia especialmente
en áreas forestales remotas durante
cuatro días cerca de 5000 hectáreas han
sido consumidas por las llamas y al
menos 1.300 familias fueron evacuadas
Con urgencia de 20 pueblos cercanos
ayer en la noche todo iba bien hasta que
escuchamos a la gente gritar fuego
salimos listos para partir como otras
personas Pero afortunadamente el fuego
subió a la montaña
Hasta eso el calor provoca este tipo de
incendios forestales hace dos días
estaba lejos de nosotros Y ayer al
amanecer llegó a nuestro pueblo pero
confiamos en que los bomberos lo
apagarán
los bomberos tienen una enorme tarea por
delante y cuentan con ayuda del ejército
marroquí y voluntarios
aquí Hay fuego por todos lados
Prepárense todos
en el cielo es como un ver aeronave
cisterna tratando de apagar las llamas
aquí en la provincia de taza los
incendios son avivados por ráfagas de
Viento y altas temperaturas que alcanzan
los 45 grados Celsius
continuamos los esfuerzos para apagar
los incendios las condiciones no son
buenas hemos perdido muchas hectáreas la
gente ha perdido sus cosechas y Los
Olivos para los próximos días el
pronóstico del clima es esperanzador
según las autoridades Se esperan
temperaturas más frescas y menos vientos